- [Gary] My first
meet up was pizza,
you know where my
first meet up is?
- [DRock] No.
- My first meet up
was in 2008 or '09,
I was doing jury duty, and
took my phone out and tweeted,
they're like you
have a two hour break but
don't leave the general area.
I'm like what?
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Change" by Mac IRV)
Case, super humbled
for the shout out, man.
I mean best day of DRock's life.
I thinking there might be a real
opportunity for your career to
change in a very positive way.
So here in Dublin, got a nice
little couple hours of a nap.
A little workout,
was more like a stretch.
Like really
tight up here, DRock.
Excited, feeling pretty good.
Feel like the energy's building.
Oh, Facebook's here.
Should probably go
there and do some negotiating.
- [DRock] (laughs)
Get some new business.
- Some new biz.
What a platform.
Dublin's been a really fun city
to watch over the last five to
seven years in tech space.
A lot of big
companies have come here,
a la Facebook.
Lot of great events, Web Summit
was here for a long time.
This event has
become a big deal.
I was here not too
long ago, show the clip.
The recall. I'm excited.
I feel like it's
gonna be a great talk.
Some other great speakers
and then quickly to Brussels.
Some more hustling.
Guess what?
It's what we do.
- [DRock] (laughs) Tried.
- I tried to give some love.
Scenes from outside of...
- [DRock] We
have the (inaudible).
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- You're a legend.
- Oh, thank you.
That's very nice.
- Do you mind if I get a selfie?
- Yeah, no worries.
Fantastic, what's you're name?
- Ben.
- Ben, thank you.
- Real good to meet you.
- [Gary] That's
a great sweatshirt.
- [Man] My man!
How are you man?
- [Gary] I'm okay.
How are you?
- Oh dope, sick.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- We'll talk later,
I already have it planned.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I'm Eric.
- Eric, okay.
It's a real pleasure.
- Baseball player guy.
- No, I get it, I get it.
How are you?
Good man.
- [Eric] Oh DRock! What's up?
- [Gary] Hi. You too. Thank you.
- Thank you you so much.
- Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
- I follow you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- You changed my life.
Thank you so much, darlin'.
Hi.
- Hi.
- [Gary] Hey, how are you?
- You remember me?
- [Gary] Yes, I do.
How are you?
Good to see you.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- Good to see you again.
- Take care.
- I gave you the
Dublin Do hat last time.
- How are you? Yes.
- I've found GaryVee
and Marie C in Dublin.
- Hey!
- Gary sleeps a little bit.
- Just a little.
Take care.
Hi, how are you?
- Hi. Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
How are you?
- Fine, my name is Mavbe.
I'm from Cuba.
- [Gary] Very nice to meet you.
- Can I have a with you picture?
- [Gary] Yeah, sure.
Awesome.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] So nice to
meet you. Take care.
- [Woman] Yeah, let's go.
- Thank you.
- [Woman] All good?
- [Gary] All good.
I did but I'm a bad student.
I don't really
look at that stuff.
But can I grab a coffee and
we can talk for two minutes about what
we're about to do?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Hey man, how are you?
Good to see you.
How are you?
- Good to see you.
We're talking at the end.
- [Gary] I can't wait.
I understood selling stuff.
And I understood brands and
I understand storytelling.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- And wine was like--
- [Woman 2] Uh-huh.
- you know, built for, right?
- [Woman 2] Yes.
- This winemaker, you know?
- [Woman 2] Totally.
- Did this.
- [Woman 2] Anybody
that drinks wine--
- That's right. So...
- I know you hear this a lot but
you are an inspiration for me.
- Thank you, my friend.
Send me an email right now.
I'll get to it on my flight.
- Absolutely.
- Thank you, that's very nice.
Thank you.
(crosstalk)
- [Woman] I was going
to go down the stairs.
- [Man] Alright.
- [Gary] Yeah, alright.
- [Man] You can do that.
- [Gary] Thank you.
DRock's gonna love this shot.
- [Woman] Oh, wait
until you see upstairs.
- [DRock] Oh.
- There you go, DRock.
- [Man 2] Gary!
(group applause)
- [Gary] How are you?
Hello.
- 'Sup?
- [Gary] Such a
pleasure. How are you, man?
Hello. Hi.
What's going on?
What's your name?
- [Woman 3] (inaudible)
- What do you do?
I get a lot of hustlers and
entrepreneurs that come to me
that want to be in the tech
business and they come up with
these ideas and then they want
a dev shop to build it for them
and they're
gonna launch this huge,
we're gonna be the next Facebook
because of this idea and then
I go you're in the tech business
and you don't
have a tech cofounder.
You know, so I
see that everyday.
So I think that the ambition
is very large and it's tech
centric, you need to have a tech
cofounder to really build an
actual big business.
I think if you're building
a fashion brand and there's
products like Magenta and
Shopify and Wordpress already in
the marketplace and your
ambition is to build a
$10 million scarf business,
well then you don't need
be the tech cofounder.
There's tools that can get you
there through Shopify and maybe
it's more about the
marketing skills or
how do you market the crayons?
You don't necessarily need, so I
think you have to go backwards.
I think the thing that
everybody makes mistakes with,
I think one of the
best thing I've ever done,
and I haven't really, I
articulate about my love of the
journey but I don't talk enough
about the way I strategize.
I kind of like playing the role
of charismatic crazy guy but
I definitely think about stuff
quite a bit and I think the best
way to win is to know
where the hell you're going.
And the reason I've been pushing
self-awareness is not everybody
here is destined to
build a $500 million thing.
I also think that it's crazy
people don't realize how amazing
it is to build a
$1 million thing.
If you can build a $1 million a
year revenue business and run on
30% net profit
you have a crazy life.
And so we have this whole world
of everybody trying to achieve
for something that's virtually
impossible and they're putting
themselves in a position where
when trying to build something
impossible they're gonna
end up working for a bank.
Because the one thing that
people haven't factored in yet
is globally the economy has been
pretty good for the last decade
or at least eight years.
And my biggest concern is
the next economic slow down.
Listen, everybody has their
own micro-economic things but
I think the reality is globally
right now things are good.
You know, things are tense about
politics but economic realities
and all the people that made
money in the 2000s or have
family money are pouring
money into startup land.
A rugby startup can actually get
money from some individual you
know that made money prior.
I mean the amount of $25,000
and $50,000 stupid checks
I've written in the last
five years, you know so
when that goes away,
what happens?
How you guys doing, good?
Good. You well?
- Nice to meet ya.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
Real pleasure, man.
Thank you, brother.
This is always
my favorite moment.
I always just love
this kind of
10, 7, 8 minutes
before taking stage.
I get into almost a
boxer mentality, I guess.
You know, I get
very competitive.
It's weird, I get
competitive with the audience.
I'm like I'm gonna fucking
(laughs) if you already love me,
I'm gonna make you love me more.
If you have no idea who I am,
I'm gonna make you know who I am
and if you don't like me and
you're cynical and you think
I'm full of crap you're
about to be exposed.
So I get into
that place mentally and
it's just a
really interesting spot.
It's very, it's this incredible
mixture even though I've done
this 100 times,
hundreds of times at this point.
It's not a nervousness, but it's
definitely a different energy.
It's a competitive energy.
It's how I used to
feel before playing like
floor hockey in high school.
Floor hockey was huge in my high
school and we played it after
school like the whole
school paid more attention to
intramural floor hockey.
They would announce the scores
to the whole
school the next morning.
It was bigger than almost every
team at our high school besides
the wrestling team and literally
every time I had a game I would
(stammering), I love clapping.
I would go and throw up almost.
Like poop my pants
like in last class,
I'd have to go to the bathroom
'cause I'd get so revved up.
That's how I get.
I get so revved up.
Are you revved up?
- I'm so revved up.
- Revved up.
So as long as it's
hanging up there the whole time
that'd be great.
- That's it?
- Thank you.
I figured I'd try to make
it challenging for you guys.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] Awesome,
thank you, guys.
- [Woman] Ladies and
gentlemen, Mr. Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience cheers and applause)
- [Gary] What's up, Dublin?
(audience cheers)
Back to the reference of that,
I've done this a lot.
I've been very blessed to be
able to speak a whole bunch in
the last decade and I can tell
you that this is a remarkable
execution for a first year event
and so I think we should all
collectively clap it
up for these fuckers.
(audience applause and cheers)
I'm super humbled to be here.
I really want to
focus on a couple things.
I'm gonna frame up this
talk, I decided just now,
'cause I like to improv
it up in clouds and dirt.
Some of you that pay attention
to me know what that means.
For the rest of you,
I'll explain it.
I think almost all of my success
and when I talk about my success
I want to make sure
I'll use this opportunity
as well to clear that up.
It's not about how
much money I make.
It's not if I actually
buy the New York Jets,
my football team
that I'm trying to buy.
It's that I just
genuinely wake up every day
being extremely happy.
I'm an extremely happy guy.
I think the world is in
a much better place than
the majority of people.
I think that I'm an optimist.
I think there's enormous
gifts in being optimistic.
I hate cynicism.
I think people lack perspective.
I think people don't realize the
math between becoming
an actual human being.
When you start understating 400
trillion to 1 is the odds that
you're actually
sitting in this seat,
it's so intense, it's hard
and I'm completely
driven by gratitude.
And so when I think
about my success as a human,
living happy so
that I can do my thing,
I think about it in clouds and
dirt and I think about it clouds
and dirt in my success of
being an entrepreneur as well.
And when I understood
the diversity of the audience
watching here and
watching in live streaming,
I thought was the right place to
go because whether your startup
founder or whether you're an
executive or whether you're an
entrepreneur or a student.
Whether you're 18 or 81, the one
thing that has been consistent
in success when I analyzed it is
this notion of clouds and dirt.
And what I mean by
that is the following;
for example, there's a lot of
marketers in here and the reason
I believe that they will not
be macro successful to their
ambitions or their wants and
dreams is because their just
headline readers.
They're just in the clouds.
Right, they've
read the articles.
They've read the books.
They've heard the thesises.
They've heard somebody
say Facebook ads don't work.
say Facebook ads do work.
They've heard people say
Snapchat doesn't matter anymore
'cause Instagram
copied the features.
They talk in theory.
They lack being a practitioner.
Others are in the dirt.
And so, for me, it's all about
top line strategy and so my top
line strategy nine
years ago was this,
that this was going to become
the primary device in our lives.
That not only was it the remote
control of our lives but that
this would become the television
and the television
would become the radio.
And so, nine years ago I
basically committed my life to
understand that if this was the
television and that Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram,
YouTube were the BBC,
and CBS, and NBC, and CNN and
Skynet and I was gonna figure
out how to make the best
shows on it whether that was me,
whether that was Wine Library,
whether that was my clients and
I promise you that
that thesis has worked out.
And I implore everybody here to
start thinking about their lives
in success, right, from a
clouds and dirt perspective.
I loved the last presentation.
I barely listen to anything.
I consume no content and so much
of what I heard as I was getting
ready was so right and makes
me think a lot about how I was
parented and how
I want to parent, right?
My macro clouds in being a
parent is I want my children to
be as happy as I am.
Because I'm real fucking happy.
(audience laughter)
So that's my clouds,
it's simple. Right?
Most parents tie their own
self-esteem into their
kids accomplishments.
That's why they put stickers of
what they did in school or what
club they're part of.
I don't care if my kids
want to be entrepreneurs,
not entrepreneurs.
If my daughter wants to make
paintings out of tomatoes,
she'll get my support 1000%.
I want to reverse engineer them.
I want to know what
they want to do, right?
That's my macro.
Then my micro is
the details of that.
The actual
practitionership around that.
Like how much do
tomatoes cost, right?
Like, that and I believe that
98, 99% of this room plays
in the middle of
clouds and dirt.
I believe that the
market plays in the middle.
A, they don't have top line
strategies and understand where
the world's going and B, they
get fancy and they don't want to
get their hands dirty.
Much like my intro,
which I appreciate,
the reason I stopped and took a
selfie and said hello and shook
hands is my who the fuck am I?
Do you know what kind of feeling
it is to have people
admire what you do?
Do you know how nice it is?
Do you know how nice
it is that somebody will
DM you and say hey?
Like do you
understand what that feels like?
You have to pull
from opposite directions.
Clouds and dirt.
That's called really
big fucking ego
(audience laughter)
and really massive humility.
Stop fucking complaining.
(audience laughter)
Thank you.
(audience applause and cheers)
One, you need to know
what your ambition is, right?
Two, you have to figure out if
what you're doing now is just
the place where you're
transitioning into the chapter
of your career or
is this the thing that
you want to try to build?
And so, if you actually decided
from a strategical standpoint
that the next two, three years
is really just about learning,
less posturing,
faking it to make it,
more just learning, tasting it,
understanding the grass
is not always greener.
Yeah, startup land is better
than finance land because people
aren't as douchy or this and
that but there's a lot of things
that aren't as good.
Like pressure.
Like it's all on you.
Like duh-duh-duh-duh-duh.
Well then if you've made the
macro decision that this is a
stepping stone and this is how
you're gonna go about the world,
all of a sudden, you're not
spending most of your time
trying to figure out how to
make the most money out of this.
You're taking it in a
totally different mindset.
You've almost got a
university-like mentality
to the execution.
You don't want to
go out of business.
have to go back to a job.
- [Man 4] No, seriously,
you inspired me to
start my own business.
- Thank you, man.
Good luck to you.
- [Man 4] Do you have
any advice for someone?
- [Gary] Patience.
Patience, you got
so much more time.
That's what's gonna trip you up.
You want it too fast.
Everybody young
wants it too fast.
This is advice
I'm giving, you know,
I'm giving advice
to everybody right now.
You really have to
know what you're doing.
At the macro and the other
thing is you have to be flexible
enough to know it changes.
What your ambition is at 19 and
15 and 22 is different what your
ambition is at 41 and you have
to be flexible in that reality.
So I think it's
a strategic answer.
You know and I think that,
I think you need to think about
tasting everything because
you're a young man and you want
to figure out what the hell you
like and what you're good at.
There's just an incredible kind
of access point of what you're
great at and what you love.
When you stumble into
being somebody like me,
you really win.
When what you're naturally great
is what you naturally love
the most and away you go.
The amount of people that
I meet every day that are great
at something but have no
interest in being a CFO.
They love, they're
insane with numbers but
they don't want to do it.
They want to sing, right?
And so, that's tough.
You see in athletics.
People don't
understand athletes.
The amount of athletes that just
do it because it was the best
way, in the same way that
somebody goes and becomes an
accountant and they
don't love competition.
And they don't love the sport.
It's crazy.
You know, when you look at them
'cause you're like one of the 15
best and they don't love it
which is why they're not the
greatest athlete of all time.
The greatest athletes
of all time are the ones
who love it and have it.
And so, I think what you
need to do is taste everything.
It's kind of like food.
You don't know what
your favorite food is
if you only eat one food.
That's why I love Q&amp;A.
That's the place where I can
bring my 301 course instead of
my 101 course.
301 course, DRock.
That's what it is.
How are ya?
So I would take advantage of
your youth and your flexibility
at this kind of age and
try to taste everything.
Play with everything figure
out what you might be good at.
What you might like and
then you make a decision.
You know, when I think about
being 41 years old and feeling
as young as I, I feel
like I'm 10 years old.
This is a GaryVee takeover.
I'm stealing
people's fucking Snapchats.
That's how we do it.
(group laughter)
You got it.
- [Man 5] I love you.
- [Gary] Stay well, man.
Take care.
I feel like I have my
whole life in front of me.
And I think that's
very difficult for
youngsters to realize that.
I'm sure some of us that
have lived a little bit longer.
Like when I was 20,
how old are you?
- [Woman 3] 26.
- [Gary] When I was 26,
41 seemed like a
long fucking way away.
(group laughter)
My eight years older
cousin who worked with me
at Wine Library
seemed old to me.
You know, he was 34
when I was 26 so 41, fuck.
It's funny for me to think
about how you're seeing me.
But I'm telling you,
you're gonna feel exactly
the way you feel
right now at 41.
And so that's interesting
because when people understand
that, you can start
deploying more patience.
Because right now
you want to prove it.
You've got, right?
Yeah, quickly.
You know, I can read that
because you're in the fake like
first words out of your mouth
always are such indicator what's
on your mind. You know?
I never cared to fake it
'til I made it because
I didn't care what people thought.
How are you?
- [Woman 4] Any advice
for us Gary from today?
- [Gary] Yes, you're gonna
die so do something about it.
- [Woman 4] No!
- It's been a pleasure.
- [Gary] Real pleasure, man.
Continued success.
When you can eliminate that,
shit changes real quick.
You know, even think
about high school and
then going into college.
High school's so tough for
people because that's the apex
of when everything's
about what other people think.
And then you love the transition
to university or the last year
of high school 'cause
you care a little less.
Right? But those first
couple years of high school,
I don't know the school system
exactly how you guys do it here,
like everybody's wrapped up in
that 12 to 17-year-old age of
like everything's about what
everybody else thinks and that's
why so many
people hate that era.
I just never went through
that luckily, just hardwiring,
good parenting,
serendipity, circumstance,
wrapping my self-esteem in
things that I was great at.
I'm not really, really good at
thinking about what a bad at.
Even in interviews the only time
I get stumped is they're like
what do you struggle with?
Or what's was a failure?
I'm like, ugh.
I just don't
even like quantify it.
I don't think it's worth it.
I think people dwell too much.
- [Woman 3] Can I ask?
- You sure can.
Look at the pink sky.
That's a pink sky.
You like pink skies, DRock?
- [DRock] Yeah,
I love pink skies.
- [Gary] DRock loves pink skies.
(group laughter)
I had a new strategy
today which is I gave a
little thought to
the first thing which
I decided was clouds and dirt.
- [DRock] Yep.
- And I then thematically
improved it the whole way.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- It's cool what I did.
That was cool.
You know what
my first meet up is?
- [DRock] No.
- [Jordan] What was it?
- My first meet up
was in 2008 or '09,
I was doing jury duty,
and took my
phone out and tweeted,
they're like you have a two
hour break but don't leave the
general area. I'm like what?
And this is
before Vayner's office,
this was before
Vayner had an office.
I was in New Jersey.
There was nowhere to go.
Couldn't get back to the
Upper East Side so I was like,
opened up Google,
I was like I have an idea.
I'm gonna open up Google maps.
I was like there's a pizza shop.
So I tweeted I'm like hey I'm
going to this pizza shop
and like seven
people showed up.
- [Jordan] Seriously?
- [DRock] Wow.
- Yeah.
- [Jordan] That's awesome.
- And that was like,
that's before meet ups.
- [Jordan] Right, yeah.
- Like that.
The phone had just come out.
- [Jordan] That's so crazy.
- And I was like what the...
(Jordan and DRock laugh)
This is cool. You know?
("CJJ Fall" by Jack Tung)
- [Man 5] My pleasure,
my man, my pleasure.
- Real pleasure.
Take care of yourself.
I hope I see you soon.
Yeah! (laughs)
Alright, gonna wake up at 1:30
in the morning to do something
pretty cool for
"The Planet of the Apps."
Secret thing,
you'll know about it.
You'll reference this,
you'll reference this
when you reference it.
But good day.
Dublin, I love you.
Brussels, I'm about to love you.
See ya.
("CJJ Fall" by Jack Tung)
Alright, DRock wants
the vlog to be better so
we're gonna appease him.
We landed in, this is what you
get when you try to produce me.
- [DRock] No.
- Ready? Here we go.
Just want you to watch this.
Yesterday, I left New York City
and I landed in Dublin this
morning at 6 A.M. or so, 7 A.M.
- [DRock] Oh my (laughs).
- [Gary] Boyd met us at--
- [DRock] Alright,
alright, alright.
(group laughter)
- [Man 5] You kind
of asked for that.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] I mean
even the driver knows.
Right, we've just been
hanging out for half a day.